I don't think president Trump needs a
vice president he's that powerful
that's a cop that's a cop-out if I've
ever heard one we know Carrie is
desperate to be Trump's VP desperate
desperate to be Trump's VP but that's
really something Trump is so good
he doesn't even need a vice president
wow there's an idea he's that powerful
as a leader he doesn't really need one
but I do hope he picks somebody who the
media fears more than they fear him is
that you and you know why I think he
should do that because then they'll stop
trying to take him down you can get the
gist of just how completely debased and
disconnected from reality Carrie lake is